et avec nous aujourd'hui pour ce club
Emma Ziza bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes hydrogue experte en
stratégie de résilience des territoires
face aux risques climatiques merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous Jean-Sol
bonjour merci d'être là sénateur les
républicains des Pyrénées-Orientales et
vous êtes auteur d'un rapport évitez la
peine sèche 8 questions sur l'avenir de
l'eau et ce sera évidemment le débat de
ce club Steve on va en parler également
avec vous je vous oublie pas la
sécheresse de votre club faut-il
s'inquiéter de la situation alors que
les nappes phréatiques sont au plus bas
notamment dans votre département
Jean-Sol des Pyrénées-Orientales où nous
irons efface à cette situation des
mesures de restriction ont été prises un
plan haut a été présenté par le
gouvernement alors est-il suffisant
faut-il revoir notre manière de
consommer l'eau ce sera l'une des
questions et la sécheresse ça fait aussi
l'actualité dans nos régions on regarde
ça tout de suite
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
à Tours on retrouve Valérie pernède
bonjour Valérie merci d'être avec nous
directrice départementale adjointe de la
rédaction de La Nouvelle République en
Indre-et-Loire on va parler des
conséquences de la sécheresse mais on
parle écologie tout de suite avec vous
puisqu'il y a une grande opération
spéciale aujourd'hui dans toute la
presse régionale vous avec la nouvelle
république évidemment supplément réalisé
avec 50 titres de la presse régionale
pour partager les solutions de nos
territoires pour faire face aux
dérèglements climatiques
oui parce que l'idée c'est de partager
avant tout des bonnes solutions des
bonnes initiatives locales et sur nos
territoires on en a beaucoup on en a
beaucoup dans tous nos territoires
ruraux et à la Nouvelle République
d'Indre-et-Loire nous sommes dans la
Vallée des Rois et nous avons choisi de
parler des prairies du roi il s'agit
d'un espace classé naturel sensible
depuis 20 ans situé au carrefour des
communes de Loches Beaulieu-lès-Loches
et pérusson c'est une vaste zone humide
inondable elle est gérée par la
Communauté de Communes loches Sud
Touraine et ici la collectivité a fait
disparaître des dizaines d'hectares de
peupliers alors cela a dégagé le paysage
et laisse aujourd'hui apparaître un joli
panorama sur la cité royale de Loches
mais cette mesure a surtout permis de
rendre disponible des milliers de mètres
cubes d'eau en effet les prairies
absorbent moins d'eau que les peupliers
on parle de 200 000 à 400 000 mètres
cubes qui sont désormais disponibles
parlant pendant la période estime
estivale ce n'est quand même pas
négligeable c'est un exemple concret de
ce qui est appelé la solution fondé sur
la nature et cela permet de favoriser en
plus la biodiversité et même de créer de
la richesse avec la production de
fourrage supplémentaire les agriculteurs
sont 8 à pouvoir produire ici du foin
pour leur bétail donc c'est du
gagnant-gagnant car leur intervention
représente aussi des économies
d'entretien pour la collectivité cet
exemple des prairies du roi et
développer avec une quinzaine d'autres
initiatives dans le supplément en quête
de demain comme vous l'avez dit Oriane
ouais justement puisque vous nous
parliez du foin Valérie c'est aussi
l'autre thème aujourd'hui qui à lire
c'est la saison des foins en Touraine et
la sécheresse a des conséquences
alors on est tout à fait en pleine
saison de la de la fenaison ici en
Indre-et-Loire si vous n'avez pas encore
eu le plaisir de vous balader au milieu
des champs mais la bonne odeur ici de
foin coupé est déjà là comme le rapporte
très justement notre journaliste Pascal
Landry les défilés des tracteurs et de
faucheuse à repris depuis le 20 mai
alors c'est plutôt en avance par rapport
à aux années précédentes ça a été
favorisé par une sécheresse par la par
le printemps humide justement avant de
devenir le printemps a été humide et
avant de devenir ensoleillée et chaud ça
a permis de favoriser la pousse c'est
pas pour autant que les agriculteurs
sont pas inquiets des sécheresses à paix
à répétition mais au moins là ils
peuvent rentrer du stock du stock de
foin parce qu'en plus d'être en avance
cette précocité donc le fourrage les
fourrages s'annoncent plutôt bon en
rendement les rendements s'annoncent
très bons on parle de 5 à 7 tonnes de
matière sèches à l'hectare qui seront
récoltés et une seconde coupe et
envisagée donc c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle pour les agriculteurs qui
étaient plutôt in pour autant ça ne veut
pas dire que c'est la panacée les grands
étaient vides donc il faut remonter les
stocks l'année dernière l'Indre-et-Loire
avait même été obligé d'aller acheter du
foin chez les voisins chez les voisins
de chez des départements voisins en
Loir-et-Cher ou en Eure-et-Loir par
exemple et cela ne doit pas cacher non
plus que que les que les éleveurs sont
de moins en moins dans nombreux vous
parlez tout à l'heure de la Une de La
Dépêche qui disait mort aux vaches en
Indre-et-Loire aussi ils sont de moins
en moins nombreux voilà tout ça est à
lire dans l'article de ce matin dans la
Nouvelle République et sur la nouvelle
république.fr merci beaucoup merci
Valérie Pernette d'avoir été avec nous
on regarde la une à un autre sujet c'est
la vente à domicile la vente à domicile
toujours tendance c'est à la Une de
votre journal ce matin merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous Valérie et on
parlait de la situation on va parler de
la sécheresse c'est évidemment le débat
de notre club d'abord Emma Aziza pour
qu'on comprenne bien avec vous quel est
aujourd'hui la situation dans le pays
quel est l'état des nappes phréatiques
non il y a deux situations il y a une
situation globale générale il faut
comprendre que la France et le pays qui
se réchauffe le plus rapidement au monde
donc déjà quand on a posé cette base on
comprend quoi se réchauffe 20% plus vite
que le reste du monde ça s'explique par
un certain nombre de paramètres
notamment le fait qu'on ait une très
grande façade littorale qui est soumis
soit au dépression soit aux phases
anticycloniques actuellement on a de
plus en plus tendance à avoir des phases
de beau temps donc d'anticyclones ça
signifie qu'au lieu de gagner de l'eau
avec des vents dominants qui viennent
d'Atlantique qui permettent ensuite de
nourrir toute la France en pluie et bien
nous perdons notre eau donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui est le premier constat
qu'il faut faire parce qu'il y a cette
question de rythme et cette question
d'adaptation qu'il va falloir mettre en
oeuvre parce que ça nous dépasse ensuite
à l'échec globale les choses ont
commencé à partir des années 2000
jusqu'en 2016 ça ne s'est pas vu sur nos
territoires et pour autant on avait les
températures historiquement élevées les
16 années les plus chaude quand on se
positionne en 2017 et bien l'ont été
après les années 2000 donc on voit à
quel point on a une bascule qui se joue
mais qui est pas visible et puis ensuite
et bien à partir de 2017 on va avoir
cette séquence d'année de sécheresse
répétitive avec une année 2021 qui va
être plus vieux sur l'ensemble du pays
sauf les Pyrénées-Orientales et la
Provence qui vont se retrouver dans des
situations de plus en plus drastiques
puisque ce stress hydrique va
s'accentuer et donc quelque part ce sont
les pays enfin les pays non les zones
on parle du pays document
mais si vous voulez ce sont vraiment les
zones qui sont les plus sous tension et
qui nous racontent une nouvelle histoire
il y a quand même une inégalité sur
notre territoire il y a une inégalité
déjà par rapport à la ressource en eau
c'est à dire que si vous positionnez à
30 km d'écart et bien vous pouvez vous
retrouver dans la plaine du Var à Nice
alors qu'il ne pleut pas et avoir pour
autant de lots à profusion alors qu'à 30
km de là vous avez le pays de faïence
qui se retrouve avec des interdictions
parce qu'il parce qu'il ne peut pas
aller plus loin pour urbaniser et qui
est encore alimenté par camion-citerne
donc on voit qu'on est très inégaux face
à la ressource en eau
pour compléter ce que ce que vous dites
au 1er mai 68% des nappes étaient
déficitaires et la situation c'est pas
vraiment rangée tout au long du mois de
mai notamment dans la moitié Nord où il
a très peu plus la sécheresse encore
aggravée puis je vais vous montrer cette
carte publiée par Christophe Béchu
c'était il y a deux semaines sur ce
compte Twitter le ministre de la
position écologique d'y vouloir
anticiper la sécheresse de l'été la
carte on va le voir voilà hiérarchie un
peu les niveaux de risque et en rouge on
le voit tout le bassin méditerranéen et
le bassin le Bassin parisien le risque
est présenté comme très pauvre le risque
de sécheresse cet été et présenté comme
très probable donc on voit il y a des
inégalités au sein même du territoire
donc on va vers un état risque on va
faire un tété à risque à deux niveaux
stress qui risque de revenir de manière
très claire de façon disparate sur le
territoire mais en tous les cas c'est ce
risque qui risque de qui va qui va
évoluer mais surtout le risque de vague
de chaleur on a actuellement quelque
chose qui se passe très très loin de
chez nous sur le Pacifique Sud ce
phénomène s'appelle el ninio il a un
pouvoir réchauffant à l'échelle
planétaire ce que nous avons vécu ces
trois dernières années l'été alors qu'on
avait un pouvoir refroidissant avec un
phénomène qui s'appelait la Ninja donc
ça signifie qu'il va falloir se préparer
aussi à du très très chaud et parmi les
départements les pays à risque gens
seuls c'est chez vous on va aller dans
les Pyrénées
les en situation et critiques Jonathan
du prix assez rendu dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales à la rencontre
d'agriculteurs inquiets et d'élus qui
cherchent des solutions au regard
le ciel est menaçant mais la pluie se
fait toujours attendre près de Perpignan
les arboriculteurs comme Joël jouannol
désespèrent de voir de l'eau s'abattre
enfin sur leurs abricotiers ça fait mal
au cœur ça fait 15 ans qu'on les soigne
que qu'on les chouchoute un petit peu
puisque on vit avec eux ils souffrent
comme ça et ben on souffre avec eux
aussi quoi Joël cultive deux hectares et
demi d'abricots des fruits qu'il ne peut
presque plus arroser l'arboriculteur
s'attend donc à une récolte tronquée
voire inexistante on voit que les arbres
commencent à avoir soit des petites
brindilles sèches
soit cette année des petits calibres
c'est une plantation qui est
complètement dans un stress hydrique
puisque avec les nouvelles directives
préfectorales on ne peut plus puiser ce
qu'on veut dans le sol on est réduit à -
80% de prélèvement donc il dit que 20%
d'alimentation à l'eau dit stress
hydrique avec 60% depuis en moins par
rapport à 2022 les mois à venir
s'annoncent très difficile dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales professionnelles et
particuliers sont soumis à d'importantes
restrictions le département a même été
placé en état de crise sécheresse par
les autorités le plus haut niveau
d’alerte alors sur le terrain certains
élus à l'image du maire de Claira tente
de trouver des solutions pour moins
gaspiller une ressource devenue rare et
si nous avons le rejet
de la station d'épuration donc avec une
eau qui est quand même particulièrement
claire regardez vous voyez c'est
vraiment de l'eau très claire puisque
nous ressortons en fait une eau usée
traitée de qualité a puisque nous sommes
à l'embouchure bien sûr de la Gly il y a
à côté de la mer donc on se doit on a
l'obligation évidemment de rejeter l'eau
la plus simple possible si elle n'est
pas potable cette eau propre se trouve
aujourd'hui gâché rejeté sans être
réutilisé dans cette rivière à sec une
hérésie que dénonce le maire la moyenne
annuelle de ce qu'on rejette à peu près
c'est 30 mètres cubes heures ça veut
dire que tous les trois jours nous
sommes en capacité de remplir une
piscine olympique ce sont des volumes
très importants sachant que nous quand
même en sachant que Claira si on une
somme une ville de 5000 habitants donc
nous sommes une petite toute petite
station
parfait face à ce constat marque Petit a
lancé une étude avec les services de
l'État ils doivent lui donner à
l'automne leur feu vert pour réinjecter
jusqu'à 20000 mètres cubes d'eau usées
par an pour l'irrigation la voirie ou
encore la lutte contre les incendies
donc aujourd'hui nous sommes où nous
avons lancé une étude de faisabilité
parce que Ben en France c'est on le
saurait aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dire
tiens demain on va utiliser les rejets
de la station d'épuration aujourd'hui je
crois qu'il y a véritablement urgence
après qui dit urgence c'est pas non plus
faire une précipitation et de faire
n'importe quoi du côté de l'État l'idée
semble faire son chemin la préfecture
qui réunit toutes les deux semaines une
cellule de crise sur la gestion de l'eau
étant passe d'autoriser plusieurs
communes à réutiliser des eaux usées
pour des usages prioritaires sur les
eaux usées effectivement c'est un volume
très important donc on a réussi à
débloquer des situations une situation
aujourd'hui mais probablement trois
nouvelles dans les prochains jours pour
réutiliser des eaux qui sortent de
station d'épuration pour des usages
prioritaires donc ça c'est fait et ça
marche et c'est des volumes très
importants maintenant il faut qu'on
arrive à amener cette eau qui sort vers
les usages prioritaires et notamment
vers le monde agricole ça c'est le point
qui nous reste à travailler mais à
l'approche d'un été difficile la
priorité pour la préfecture des
Pyrénées-Orientales et de garantir
l'accès en eau potable aux habitants et
touristes actuellement 23 communes du
département ont un risque prononcé de
rupture en eau potable il y a beaucoup
de choses dans ce sujet beaucoup dont on
va débattre mais en commençant par le
début on l'a vu cette arboriculteur
c'est l'inquiétude dans votre
département Jean-Sol des conséquences de
la sécheresse pour les cultures oui
c'est effectivement une inquiétude je
pense légitime pour avoir été sur le
terrain il y a quelques semaines
notamment lors de la venue des ministres
du ministre fhéno
nous avons nous avons nous avons nous
avons pu voir de de nos propres yeux les
dégâts déjà au niveau des cultures alors
on parle de l'arboriculture on a pu voir
que des fruits étaient vraiment réduits
à leur plus simple expression et puis
sur des terrains où il y avait un minima
une irrigation les fruits étaient déjà
un peu plus gros alors si vous voulez
ces arboriculteurs sont inquiets non
seulement pour les récoltes là qui sont
imminentes à venir mais aussi pour
certains pour la survie de leurs
exploitations puisqu'on sait très bien
que pour avoir un terrain
de d'arbres de ce type là il faut quand
même quelques années
des conséquences sur les cultures sur du
plus long terme ou est-ce que c'est
rattrapable pour vous et Mazda est-ce
que si il pleut beaucoup dans les
prochaines semaines c'est ça peut être
rattrapé ou pas oumin ou c'est un peu
trop tard on a quand même des nappes qui
sont souffrances depuis trop d'années on
estime qu'une nappe qui se tarie elle
met 10 ans avant de se reconstituer elle
se reconstitue jamais complètement donc
de toutes les façons la teinte et là et
on voit très bien qu'on est qu'on est à
la fin j'ai envie de dire d'un système
où il va falloir qu'effectivement on
réfléchisse autrement sur notre
consommation en eau sur ces territoires
et bien il va falloir essayer
d'optimiser la gestion de cette eau
c'est sans doute le territoire sur
lequel il va falloir chercher le plus à
innover parce qu'on n'arrive vraiment
face au mur j'ai envie de dire parce que
depuis le début de l'année il n'y a
jamais quasiment aucune pluie sur toute
la région que ce soit
enfin entre Perpignan et la frontière
espagnole et bien on a l'impression que
cette zone est oubliée complètement par
les pluies et le peu de pluie qui est
passé elle est passée d'un côté de
l'autre côté des Alberts en Espagne elle
est passée ensuite sur Marseille et
toute la zone mais encore une fois les
Pyrénées-Orientales ont été vraiment
dans une situation extrême donc
effectivement on est dans cette période
face donc déjà repenser l'agriculture
ben ça va être on est quand même dans
des valises et des vallées que je
connais très bien parce que j'ai grandi
là-bas donc effectivement que ce soit
les cerisiers et les abricotiers on est
sur des territoires ou un arbre mais des
années avant de pouvoir fournir ses
fruits c'est la même chose d'ailleurs
que ce soit pour les arbres fruitiers ou
les arbres en ville si on ne réfléchit
pas à une manière d'alimenter ses arbres
en eau et qu'on se retrouve face à des
arrêtés d'interdiction d'alimentation en
eau on voit que de grandes villes ont
planté massivement des arbres et trois
mois après ils étaient morts donc il va
falloir effectivement se préparer
autrement avec des solutions qui sont
loin d'être parfaites mais en tous les
cas qui peuvent être intéressantes que
ce soit la réutilisation des eaux usées
ou même dans ce cas là localement la
décennalisation même si c'est loin
d'être la panacée on pourra en reparler
on va en parler puisque c'est aussi l'un
des angles du sujet de Jonathan mais
l'autre question qui se pose dans votre
territoire on le voit dans le sujet
c'est le risque sur l'eau potable il y a
un vrai risque aujourd'hui
nous en avons fait malheureusement
l'expérience il y a quelques semaines
sur quatre communes du département qui
sont retrouvés alimentés par par des
bouteilles d'eau des des palettes
arrivées par camion sur l'initiative des
mers et bien évidemment ça représente là
aussi un budget et on est quand même
garant ben de ces taux et surtout de la
qualité de de ces taux que l'on apporte
aux administrés alors bon là il y avait
quatre communes mais il est fort
possible qu'il y a né qu'il y ait
d'autres et il faut effectivement qu'on
est cette capacité non seulement
d'adaptation j'ai envie de dire mais
mais mes d'anticipation et c'est un
combat qui doit se faire
individuellement mais aussi
collectivement les initiatives qui qui
pointeront ici est là si elles sont
isolées à mon sens n'apporteront pas
grand chose que ce soit une prise de
conscience bien sûr
tout à fait aujourd'hui avec les tomes
sauf dans notre département Monsieur le
Préfet a pris les choses à moi le corps
et à réuni il y a à peu près deux trois
mois un comité de de sécheresse
d'ailleurs il poursuit ses réunions je
maniais de manière à mettre autour de la
table amène tous les tous les acteurs
qui soient là la Chambre d'Agriculture
mais aussi les représentants du tourisme
puisque dans notre département on a
quand même deux pans de l'économie qui
sont l'agriculture la viticulture le
maraîchage l'arboriculture mais aussi
les éleveurs dont on n'a pas parlé et
puis ce pan ou se voler du du tourisme
puisque on arrive donc à l'été et on
espère aussi on appelle de nos vœux que
les que les touristes viennent quand
même dans notre département malgré
toutes toutes ces inquiétudes
notamment sur le tourisme sur l'eau
potable puisqu'on l'a vu c'est l'un des
sujets est-ce que l'eau potable ça
risque de devenir une ressource rare
dans notre pays à maaziza et bien il y a
encore quelques années c'était vraiment
un scénario de science-fiction on
imaginait absolument pas que ce soit
possible d'ailleurs en 2005 on avait
deux communes qui avaient été rupture
d'alimentation d'eau potable ça remonte
il y a tout de même 15 ans et le
ministère à l'époque de l'époque de
l'écologie avait lancé un très grand
programme de sensibilisation de la
population et c'est de là qu'on retient
le fait qu'il faut couper le robinet
lorsqu'on se lave les dents donc il y
avait à l'époque que deux communes et
une en milieu insulaire en plus que
c'était Bel-Air donc là on voit que plus
de 1300 communes l'été dernier on a
passé un cap colossal et il va falloir
comprendre qu'effectivement cette
bascule est en cours chaque année nous
n'avons pas les mêmes communes qui se
retrouvent en rupture d'alimentation
parce que parfois ce sont des problèmes
de réseau parfois les forages ne sont
pas exploitables il y a quand même plus
de 4000 forages qui aujourd'hui pourrait
être exploité pour des circulation et ne
le sont pas par faute de taux de
pesticides trop importants donc il va
falloir aussi que l'on travaille
massivement sur la protection de cette
ressource en eau quand elle devient rare
il faut la protéger et il va falloir
notamment recréer ces cycles de l'eau
localement avec peut-être une adaptation
massive de l'agriculture si je prends le
cas des Pyrénées-Orientales vous avez
normalement un cycle de l'eau qui est
carrément visible quand vous remontez
dans la vallée du vallespire vous voyez
en fin de journée ces nuages se
formaient et ces nuages finir par
précipiter ce phénomène là ne se produit
plus on a notamment un la tramontagne
qui est en train de carrément
disparaître localement ça signifie qu'il
y a des processus en cours mais qu'à
partir du territoire on peut les recréer
à condition de remettre en place de
nouvelles solutions notamment plus
basées sur l'agroforesterie et on va
parler justement des solutions parce que
l'autre point qui est assez marquant
dans le reportage de Jonathan c'est
cette question de la réutilisation de
l'eau d'abord si on va faire un point
avec vous puisque l'exécutif if a
présenté son plan haut et ça fait partie
des mesures oui c'est Emmanuel Macron
lui-même et qui s'en est chargé c'était
le 30 mars dernier lors d'un déplacement
dans les Hautes-Alpes il a annoncé un
plan de sobriété sur l'eau pour tous les
secteurs économiques cela concernerait
aussi les particuliers qui pourraient
payer plus cher s'il consomme trop
écouté
les premiers mètres cubes
sont facturés à un prix modeste proche
du prix coûtant
c'est ça l'évolution vers laquelle on va
aller tarification progressive pour tout
le monde ça correspond à l'eau dont nous
avons tous besoin pour boire nous laver
et pratiquer les usages domestiques du
quotidien ensuite au-delà d'un certain
niveau le prix du mètre cube sera plus
élevé et c'est normal pour les
consommations que j'appellerai de
confort et pour inciter à la sobriété au
total 53 mesures ont été annoncées parmi
elles la réutilisation des eaux usées
objectives 10% de réutilisation d'ici
2030 on est actuellement autour à moins
de 1%
Emmanuel Macron qui est assis annoncé un
plan de sobriété on en parlait secteur
par secteur la mise en place d'un
ÉcoWatt de l'eau un programme
d'investissement pour adapter les
centrales nucléaires au changement
climatique ou encore la mise en place de
bassines sébacina qui font l'objet de
polémique elle pompe l'eau pendant
l'hiver pour que les agriculteurs
puissent arroser leur culture pendant
l'été pour Emmanuel Macron toutes ces
mesures visent à être au rendez-vous de
l'eau il s'agit d'un enjeu de
souveraineté alimentaire selon le
président est-ce qu'elle permettront
d'être au rendez-vous est-ce qu'elles
sont assez ambitieuses ces mesures et ma
vie alors déjà il y a une très grande
différence entre ce qui a été annoncé
par Emmanuel Macron et la réalité des 53
mesures on retrouve absolument pas les
bassines donc on voit qu'on a quand même
tout de même chercher à apaiser
certaines fédérations parce que c'est
quand même tout de même étonnant de voir
à quel point il y a un discours et quand
on regarde dans le détail et bien ça n'a
rien à voir donc déjà c'est 53 mesures
sont bonnes sont efficaces et sont
plutôt ambitieuses la question va être
le temps de leur mise en oeuvre
personne n'a encore aujourd'hui pensé
dans les entreprises petite ou grande
d'ailleurs ce qui on parle d'empreintes
carbone on nous parle absolument pas
d'empreinte haut que va être ce plan de
sobriété en eau il va falloir mettre en
place des méthodologies essayer de
comprendre ce que l'on peut faire et
puis on a eu un peu ce sentiment d'une
baguette magique ne vous inquiétez pas
on va réutiliser l'eau usée ça va être
simple ça fantastique ça fait 30 ans
qu'on réutilise l'eau usée en France on
essaye c'est pas toujours facile parce
que parfois c'est pas du tout rentable
parfois ça fait plutôt du mal au milieu
puisque cette eau elle est nécessaire au
milieu naturel qui n'en a pas assez
c'est plutôt très intéressant en
pourtant littoral ça allait beaucoup
moins dans les terres donc attention à
cet effet
c'est une solution intéressante par
exemple dans les Pyrénées-Orientales
puisqu' au lieu de rejeter cette eau à
proximité de la mer et c'est une eau qui
sort de station d'épuration il est
beaucoup plus pertinent de la réutiliser
et via des moyens qui sont de plus en
plus performants aujourd'hui donc là oui
on optimise la ressource en eau de
manière intelligente dans une zone et
oui ou la moindre goutte d'eau vaut son
pesant
quand même dans le reportage de Jonathan
du priaza on voit ce maire le rejet de
son usine d'épuration qui est de l'eau
qui paraît propre qui est propre et qui
est rejeté dans une rivière à sec c'est
assez aberrant il faut travailler
là-dessus j'en sais rien je pense que
c'est sur la réutilisation des eaux
effectivement il faut travailler comme
le madame à côté ça fait quand même
quelques années que certaines communes
se sont emparés du sujet ont investi et
on travaillait sur la réutilisation des
eaux usées bien évidemment il faut aller
plus loin d'ailleurs c'est une de l'eau
qui est rejetait dans des rivières à sec
j'ai pas forcément la réponse ce que je
peux vous dire aujourd'hui ce qu'il y a
des dispositifs techniques qui
permettent justement de traiter les os
et de ressortir une eau de qualité qui
puisse arroser on l'a vu les golfs les
espaces verts qui puissent servir à
l'industrie qui puisse servir au
nettoyage à curé etc etc la
réutilisation des eaux usées c'est une
c'est une piste d'ailleurs que nous
avions mentionné dans notre rapport dont
je pense que le gouvernement c'est quand
même assez imprégné nous n'avons pas 53
mesures mais huit mesures donc un
certain nombre qui me semble assez
concrète et pragmatique après moi la
question que nous avons une une
justement une dispositif de
réutilisation des eaux usées à
Saint-Cyprien qui qui fonctionnent très
très bien
en bord de mer qui permet de mettre de
l'eau dans des citerne c'est citerne
partent dans les endroits qui allons qui
en ont besoin ça fonctionne très très
bien l'eau est filtrée
c'est pas un problème de réglementation
qu'il faut changer il va falloir que ça
évolue effectivement
et surtout le comment dirais
[Musique]
-je moi l'expansion est donnée les
moyens aussi parce que tout cela un coup
de c'est bien joli de dire il faut
réutiliser les eaux usées mais pour les
collectivités notamment au plan
budgétaire il va falloir quand même les
aider pour pouvoir mettre en place ces
dispositifs après c'est une solution
c'est une proposition parmi tant
d'autres mais je pense qu'au point au
départ effectivement il faut que chacune
et chacun fasse un effort en matière de
en matière de de sobriété mais la
question des moyens se pose alors moi je
si vous voulez j'ai tendance à dire
aussi parce que les hydrogéologues
notamment madame ça fait quand même
quelques emmener les scientifiques nous
alertes quand même sur ce réchauffement
climatique sur ce changement climatique
sur son impact et on se rend compte
aujourd'hui que on est au pied du mur et
là il faut y aller quoi il faut y aller
très très vite et j'espère qu'on ne va
pas sur moi ce qu'il me préoccupe
aujourd'hui c'est c'est le traitement en
tout cas de de ces conflits d'usage et
puis de s'aggraver
et puis qu'on évite surtout de rentrer
dans une guerre de l'eau qui à mon sens
on en est pas trop trop loin on est pas
loin d'une gare de l'oreille ça devient
très complexe là on parle des 53 mesures
du gouvernement mais on ne parle pas du
guide sécheresse qui est passé un peu
inaperçu mais qui nous raconte là encore
quelque chose de nouveau à partir du
moment où vous aurez un département qui
sera en niveau d'alerte crise et bien
vous ne pourrez plus remplir votre
piscine vous ne plus pourrez plus non
plus remplir une piscine collective ça
signifie que pour tous les
établissements de plein air il va y
avoir une mise en danger très claire de
leur activité est-ce qu'on ne sera
capable de trouver des solutions
disciples de moi ça semble très complexe
mais au moins il faut prendre le taureau
par les cornes j'ai envie de dire et
essayez de regarder les solutions qui
pourraient exister attention aux
mauvaises solutions typiquement les
bassines qui sont des retenues
substitution sont ces solutions de mal
adaptation reconnues par tous les
scientifiques pourquoi parce que
prélever de l'eau dans la nappe
phréatique dans un moment où elle est
censée alimenter les cours d'eau et le
taux d'humidité des sols donc permettent
la fertilité des sols et bien si vous
enlevez cette partie pour quelque part
cela qu'à paraît et le mettre dans une
zone déterminée vous empêchez en réalité
l'intégralité du cycle de l'eau et vous
arrêtiez un territoire alors que si vous
récupérez de l'eau de pluie et bien là
c'est beaucoup plus intelligent pourquoi
parce que sur 100% depuis qu'il tombe le
2/3 repart dans l'atmosphère si vous la
captez avant vous pourrez l'optimiser
donc ça signifie qu'il va falloir
réfléchir différemment mais jouer
intelligemment avec le cycle de l'eau et
pas contre le cycle de l'eau et ne
jamais oublier que que c'est nappes
phréatiques sont le socle même de nos
territoires qui nous permettent d'avoir
des sols humides qui nous permettent
d'avoir justement cette végétation
luxuriante sur lequel elle s'appuie et
tous nos cordons sont déjà en souffrance
ça signifie tout le vivant derrière faut
jamais oublier qu'on fait ce vivant et
que le saumon il finit par remonter
qu'on a fini dans notre assiette et si
on veut que ça continue au moins qu'on
puisse avoir de la pollinisation des
fruits des légumes ou encore derrière
une chaîne trophique vous savez ce qui
mange qui ben à la fin c'est toujours
nous qui seront impactés donc il va
falloir le préserver au maximum j'en
sais alors en un mois est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes inquiet pour
votre département on l'a vu aussi bien
au niveau des agriculteurs qu'au niveau
du tourisme on nous en parliez tout à
l'heure et moi je suis inquiet pour
notre département en termes de
proposition encore une fois de de de de
de solution et de pistes d'amélioration
moi je pense qu'il y a des actions à
court terme à moyen et long terme à
court terme nous en avons parlé on n'a
pas parlé des fuites aussi sur les sur
les réseaux
malgré là aussi l'investissement
l'implication la mobilisation de
l’homaire et de nos élus ils sont aussi
confrontés à des budgets qui fait que à
un moment donné on a un taux de fuite
qui participe et effectivement la
conservation de cette eau et à son
acheminement vers vers les vers les
foyers je pense que là aussi il va
falloir aider une fois de plus
budgétairement financièrement nos élus
pour pouvoir avancer et faire en sorte
que les réseaux
est quand même une
un taux acceptable aujourd'hui me
semble-t-il
merci beaucoup et ma visa d'être venu on
va continuer à parler de ce qui est
peut-être la guerre de l'eau on va voir
l'une des conséquences c'est dans la
presse régionale
[Musique]
et Steve à la une de la presse une usine
qui jette l'éponge en Bretagne
l'entreprise Bridor annonce l'abandon de
son projet d'installation en
Ille-et-Vilaine à Liffré tout près de
Rennes si elle a une de Ouest-France le
groupe leduve souhaite écrire une usine
de viennoiserie industrielle un projet
qui date de six ans mais qui était
contesté par des défenseurs de
l'environnement il lui reprochait
notamment l'utilisation de terre
agricoles et une quantité d'eau trop
importante pour fonctionner ils ont
engagé des recours en justice et le
groupe a donc décidé de jeter l'éponge
Oriane le rapport accablant de la
commission oui à retrouver dans
Corse-Matin aujourd'hui la commission
parlementaire chargée d'enquêter sur
l'agression mortelle divan Colonna en
prison a publié son rapport ce mardi et
il est très sévère grave défaillance
dans l'appréciation de la dangerosité du
côté tenue rigueur excessive à
l'encontre du militant indépendantiste
série de dysfonctionnements d'ordre
général voilà ce qu'on peut lire dans ce
compte-rendu parlementaire adopté à
l'unanimité des 28 députés de la
commission Corse-Matin se demande s'il
s'agit d'un épilogue ou d'un prélude
Oriane électrique c'est fantastique oui
c'est un vert un joli vert qui pourrait
signer de l'écrivain Bruno Le Maire mais
qui vient bien de nos confrères de la
Voix du Nord qui justement mettre le
ministre de l'économie en une ce matin
oui parce que Bruno Le Maire a inauguré
ce mardi dans le Pas-de-Calais la toute
première usine de batterie électrique du
territoire objectif rattrapé notre
retard sur les constructeurs chinois
l'usine va produire 40 GW ici 2030
Oriane cocorico pour terminer oui le
premier unique avion certifié 100%
électrique au monde veulent en France
plus précisément dans les villes du Mans
c'est à une du même livre aujourd'hui le
club des ailes du Maine est l'un des
premiers en France a posséder un avion à
0 carbone c'est peut-être ça l'avenir si
vous voulez le piloter rendez-vous à
l'aérodrome d'Arnage merci beaucoup si
vous irez peut-être je suis invité on
espère qu'il vous a entendu merci pour
cette revieweresse merci beaucoup
Emmanuel
d'avoir été avec nous pour pouvoir ou
revoir cette émission c'est notre
nouvelle plateforme publique sénat.fr
prochain rendez-vous à 15h la séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement et
à 18h Thomas Hulk pour sens publique et
nous on se retrouve demain très bonne
journée
[Musique]